hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to 4g and lte explained so what
is 4g exactly i mean we've seen it on
all sorts of carrier branding and
commercials and stuff sometimes we see
it on the back of our phones or on the
front of our phones but there's no real
widely accepted definition of 4g so
let's try to explain that so as far as
the name goes 4g the g stands for a
generation of wireless technology with
each new generation you get
significantly faster data speeds but it
becomes incompatible with the previous
generation so you'll never see a 3g
phone working on a 4g network and there
are carriers that have both 3g and 4g
networks like verizon we'll get to that
in a second the first g the original g
was the old analog cellular systems
they're obviously super slow 2g moves to
digital but they are still very very
slow somewhere around 10 to 200 kilobits
per second the first iphone was 2g fun
fact 3g is a much faster digital and it
starts at around 384 kilobits per second
4g systems like lte and ymax claim to
initially start out around 5 megabits
per second which is a lot higher than
all the rest we've already seen but 4g
isn't just faster than 3g the 4g
networks also tend to have a lot more
capacity than the 3g network so you're
going to see a lot less bandwidth caps
when you're on 4g when you're on 3g you
tend to be limited and when you're on 4g
you'll see a lot more higher data plans
but the complication that has people
wondering what really is 4g is the fact
that there are some really modern 3g
networks like we'll get to in a second
that are actually faster than the
beginnings of the 4g networks for
example hspa plus
it's really it's 3g basically but it's
really really fast 3g somewhere around 7
megabits per second it's been evolved
for so long t-mobile runs on hspa plus
network and they plan to continue to
evolve it to get it up to 30 megabits
per second so instead of being left out
of the 4g chatter that's going to be the
way of the future they just figured
they'd stamp a 4g sign on their hsba
plus network and just declare it 4g
because who's going to argue and one
other difference between 3g and 4g since
we haven't mentioned it already is that
in order to hop on the brand new 4g
network like i said it's probably
incompatible well it is incompatible
with the 3g network so you need one of
those new 4g radios in your device and
those are some very very power hungry 4g
radios this is why in the united states
we pretty much haven't seen any device
any smartphone at all with both quad
core and 4g because that's just way too
much power for a single battery to
handle phones these days have you know
huge screens they have extremely fast
ram these great processors but to throw
4g on top of all that would be a huge
power suck for the battery and that's
why we haven't seen something like the
htc one x which is quad core overseas
come to the united states quad core if
it's coming to the united states and you
want to sell well
you just got to put 4g in there and
that's why they're saying all right
we'll make a dual core and hopefully
it'll have enough power to last through
the day will we ever see a 4g quad-core
device in the united states
i don't really know i did a little bit
of a rant on battery technology already
and hopefully if battery tech improves
we'll be able to see one maybe the
galaxy s3 will be quad-core in the
united states but i don't really know
yet i'm hoping maybe the next iphone i
don't know competition is good uh either
way hopefully this video helped to
explain 4g for you guys and just in case
you were wondering lte stands for
long-term evolution and hspa stands for
high-speed packet access i don't really
know why those are named that way but
either way give a thumbs up on this
video if you learned something hopefully
you guys like the explained video series
and if you also have anything else that
you want to be explained something
technical that i could break down and
make a fun interesting video let me know
in the comments section below that like
button but either way thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video peace
so
you